Pimp My Ride fans may have believed the MTV
show acted like a fairy godmother for car
lovers who couldn't afford tricked-out rides.
Peek under the hood of this gearhead favorite,
however, and instead of finding a shiny V-8,
there might be a hamster on a wheel.
There's no arguing Pimp My Ride's popularity
and impact on pop culture, but the show's
behind-the-scenes reality makes the show seem
more like a lemon.
Many cars with mechanical issues left with
the same problems
There's nothing glamorous about fixing a major
mechanical issue, and Pimp My Ride apparently
didn't try too hard.
Instead, the crews seemed to use the cars
as elaborate advertisements for their sponsored
businesses by installing eye-catching fixtures.
Some problems were fixed, but contestants
have claimed the labor was sloppy, while others
report the cars stopped working entirely days
later.
One contestant, Seth Martino, said in his
Reddit AMA that his pimped car was a "polished
turd" that he couldn't even drive—until
he spent $1,700 of his own money to replace
the engine that the crews neglected to work
on.
But hey!
At least he got a robot arm that can ding
a triangle for some reason!
"Check that out."
"That thing is crazy!"
Great job, guys.
The process took months
The show gives the impression that people
got their cars back days later, the paint
still wet, but some car owners report it actually
took upwards of seven months.
Shops had to order parts or make custom details
that required time.
To top it off, former contestants told Huffington
Post that MTV didn't always provide an alternate
car for the entire time.
Seth Martino told HuffPo that they only paid
for a rental for the first two months—and
worse, because of his young age, most reputable
companies wouldn't even rent a car to him.
Bogus Backstories
When contestants didn't seem interesting enough,
the show added some spice.
Some cars were doctored to look worse in the
"before" shots.
Martino revealed in his AMA that producers
planted candy throughout his car.
He wrote:
"I know I'm fat, but they went the extra mile
to make me look extra fat by telling the world
that I kept candy all over my seat and floor
just in case I got hungry."
This begs the question: why humiliate a contestant
on a show with a guy who looks like this as
a regular cast-member?
Well, apparently the producers wanted a reason
to install a cotton candy machine.
Worse, the cotton candy machine didn't have
a protective hood.
Martino never even used it after the shoot.
Surprised?
The element of surprise is great for good
television, and Pimp My Ride always started
with an unexpected knock on a jalopy-owner's
door.
But how many do you really think answered
at just the right moment?
That's why car owners were prepped beforehand.
Some contestants knew they were finalists,
while others were already mic'ed up and ready
for retakes.
Contestant Jake Glazier explained that producers
didn't think he seemed excited enough, so
they made him do it again.
This is what faked overreaction looks like.
Other times, if a person's house didn't seem
right for television, they'd go to a different
home altogether.
For a show starring a guy named Xzibit, they
sure did keep a bunch of weird stuff under
wraps, huh?
"Alright you need two things.
You need these, you've officially been pimped,
alright?
Get outa here..."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you thought was the sketchiest part of Pimp
My Ride...